nous décollons maintenant pour le japon
avec camille lambert le pays du soleil
levant est mis à l'honneur à saint
quentin en yvelines avec la nouvelle
édition du festival de bd bubble sky et
oui deuxième édition plus exactement qui
se tient jusqu'au 4 mars dans toutes les
médiathèques du réseau de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
programmation se révèle riche et varié
contes projections de films jeux
animations et mangal y en a pour tous
les goûts et pour tous les âges deux
expositions sont aussi installées l'une
à la médiathèque du canal c'est bubble
stick qu'on voit sur ces images
l'autre est à la médiathèque
saint-exupéry julien au maire
responsable du festival nous en dit plus
sur ces expositions
pour ce qui est des blue bulls tic en
fait c'est un travail qui a fait la
médiathèque du canal avec le
conservatoire de montigny et céder des
stickers faits par les enfants qui vont
être collé un petit peu dans toute la
médiathèque et pour ce qui est de
l'autre l'exposition qui osent puisque
c'est la maison d'édition crown qui nous
la fournit ça va tourner sur de manga
donc justement un manga pour les jeunes
plutôt my rocket est mieux qu'un manga
qui a été un des cartons l'année
dernière est un manga seinen sur les
chercheurs sur les chercheurs d'or qui
s'appelle et les mangas dont parle
julien omnes vous pouvez en voir
quelques images à l'écran dans chaque
lieu d'exposition ont été installés des
mangas qui sa prochaine au japon c'est
un lieu entre le cybercafé et la
bibliothèque où chacun peut venir lire
des mangas en libre service
le principe a été repris et installés
dans les deux médiathèques de saint
quentin en yvelines
il est aussi des ateliers cette fois et
des professionnels oui avec le mangaka
yoshimi kata hirabe dessinateur de manga
prochain atelier prévu ce samedi à
elancourt et mardi à plaisir et aux
clayes-sous-bois il vous apprendra à
perfectionner votre technique ou tout
simplement découvrir le dessin manga
alors pour ceux qui comme moi sont pas
très doués avec un crayon pour les
cinéphiles et des projections
oui effectivement on ya pensé avec
d'humilier zaki notamment difficile de
passer à côté de ce réalisateur quand on
évoque le japon pour rappel c'est lui
qui a réalisé les très connus princesse
mononoké le voyage de chihiro
c'est aussi le cours font date heure du
studio ghibli le 24 février sera diffusé
le nom inconnu porco rosso au grenier à
sel de trappes
le film se passe dans
l'entre-deux-guerres et raconte
l'histoire de marco un pilote qui vient
se couvrir les personnes en difficulté à
bord de son hydravion rouge on regarde
un extrait de la bande annonce
nous ferons
[Musique]
il ya aussi un autre film culte akira au
grenier à sel de trappes
c'est un film d'animation réalisé par
katsuhiro otomo adapté du manga du même
nom lui il est projeté au grenier à sel
de trappes le 24 février à 20 heures il
est sorti en 1988
l'intrigué se passe après la troisième
guerre mondiale dans un neo tokyo
apocalyptique un jeune garçon est
capturé par l'armée et fait l'objet
d'expériences scientifiques
il est par la suite mêlée à la légende
d'akira un sauveur qui serait doté d'une
grande puissance
le film est considéré comme un classique
du genre
[Musique]
à qui la
pour les ateliers ou pour les films
pensez à vous inscrire tous les
renseignements sont disponibles sur le
site internet cd médiathèque de saint
quentin en yvelines
merci kamini alors un mois pour voyager
sans quitter l'agglomération est quoi
exactement est bon